[Music]
now more disturbing evidence tonight of
the lawlessness taking over america's
democratic-run cities for example look
at your screen out in los angeles thefts
against cargo trains are now spiking and
the union pacific railroad is now
blasting failed far left district
attorney george gascon for lenient
sentences that downgrade syria's theft
charges to a lesser offense and
according to union pacific train
container theft increased by a whopping
160 percent just from 2020 to 2021 in la
county and of course it's not only
property la's failure to address growing
crime well that's costing lives nearly
every single day tonight we're
continuing to follow the murder of grad
student ucla graduate student her name
is brianna kupper who's fatally stabbed
over the weekend while working at an la
furniture store the lapd is now offering
a 250 thousand dollar reward for
information that leads to the capture of
this suspect now identified as 31 year
old sean lavalle smith but i'll ask
again tonight how many more of these
stories do we have to cover before far
left district attorneys start taking
this seriously you got democratic-run
cities and states failing to protect
people and failing to protect property
and failing to prevent lawlessness from
completely taking over here with
reaction nationally syndicated radio
talk show host founder of elder for
america pac and former gubernatorial
candidate larry elder you know larry i
look at this young woman she's killed
look what's happening with the railroads
correct me if i'm wrong when they
defunded the lapd and cut its budget
wasn't it vice president kamala harris
to praise the lapd
well that's right kamala harris said
that we need to reimagine the police
department and they diverted a lot of
funds for so-called youth programs and
shortly after gavin newsom survived the
recall election sean he signed a bunch
of bills one of them was to reduce crime
enhancement because he felt that a large
number of these bad guys are gang
members and they're black and brown
people and therefore they are victims of
systemic racism because too many of them
are black and brown never mind that the
very victims that they claim that they
care about are also disproportionately
black and brown and regarding this young
lady from ucla this graduate student
and these train robberies they're all
connected they can be traced right back
to our soft on crime d.a
gavin newsom george george gascon that
gavin newsom supported and that george
soros supported and guess who else
supported it uh maxine waters maxine
waters lives in hancock park this is the
upscale area where this young lady was
working in a furniture store so the very
policies and people that that
people like maxine waters supported are
coming very close to home so maybe now
they'll reconsider some of their
policies that have imperiled the lives
of citizens uh in l.a county and in los
angeles i don't think so larry i mean
because it's getting worse i mean i see
they've doubled down on defund dismantle
they've doubled down on nobel laws they
doubled down on charging people with
serious crimes and reducing the charges
to misdemeanors that's common now in
pretty much every blue city and
and democrat run state in the country
yeah but a growing number of people are
now beginning to reconsider things like
proposition 47 that allows you to steal
up to 950 bucks not just a day but
per store uh and if you get caught the
worst that happens is they write you a
ticket as a misdemeanor and of course
you have you have cashless bail so you
don't need to show up and then we got
proposition 57 that reduces a whole
bunch of categories of crime to
nonviolent crimes and they include
assault on a police officer that's now a
non-violent crime
serial arson is now a non-violent crime
rape of an intoxicated victim is now a
nonviolent crime and felony domestic
battery is now a nonviolent crime but a
growing number of people are beginning
to reconsider these policies because now
it's coming close to home when i ran for
governor sean a lot of people said when
is california going to hit rock bottom
and i said uh when the crime comes to
places like like brentwood yeah bel air
in malibu and now the crime is coming to
those areas and now gavin is talking
about a single-payer health system and
doubling the state tax in california i
mean you can't make this up uh they had
a shot you could have been a great
governor um
californians will be regretting that
thank you for being with us we have more
hannity right after this